is the show just kind of what's on your
mind or well yes sex and the lack of it
I appreciate you but you know you get to
be a certain age and you just can't let
you know you I just said I'll go dudes
I'll be like oh but now I look and I
think Oh too young too young and I just
feel bad because I'd like to all the
other people my age so I feel like I can
give them some pointers and making them
available it's you know it's about life
and fun and yeah and wanting to get to
have a good time again and one of the
things you do a Q&A session yes I did
with the audience yeah and I just wonder
is that always the same or do you notice
a difference when you come to Britain do
they ask different questions to the
Americans well they're not as interested
in who I boned the Brits are more
interested in and who who inspired me in
America they ask you who you go oh my
god yeah don't you know there's a list
floating around
you know I'm gonna sack researcher not a
Satanist
I burned it you know because you don't
tabloids I come from the time before the
cameras were out so everything was in
the tabloids so if you went out to lunch
with somebody you were having sex with
him you're about to move in and so
people always say so what was it like
when you like we're with that guy I
think which guy and they say one that
you married and I say you know I've been
married nine times I don't know which
one you're talking about
[Applause]
[Music]
you